[Music]
Hi how are you good how are you I'm very
good thank you for doing this with us as
the managing director of the F1 Academy
leading the charge for women how could I
refuse taking your own forap that's an
honor this isn't what
usually anybody except for the drivers
get to do when they come to the track
this is not a normal experience that I
get to have because of you and with you
and I think I'm going to live out every
person's fantasy including my own so and
let's hope it lives up to expectations I
just had Burger so I feel like I smell a
lot like raw onion before you go in the
car yeah that's not going to be good for
either of
us you started like go-karting when you
were forgive me if I get this number
wrong was it like seven or eight exactly
ex y yeah I got a little cart for my eth
birthday and I was that is little girl
that loved speed competition and when
someone told me oh you can't do that it
made me even more determined to do it
what's it like to be a woman in this
world I think because there's a deep
passion for racing I kind of don't let
the other stuff bother me there's a lot
of noise around my gender about being
the only one but in the end I'm just
here because I love to be here amazing
such an inspiration thank you she's
going to be an engineering Studio
fantastic well done thank you good Susie
you're fans you just got to go out there
do your thing be fast and the rest takes
care of itself we're a big fan of yours
oh thank you so much I feel so like
excited to watch everybody fan out on
you I'm not sure it's not you no one
said a thing to me we're in your world
and you are the
Superstar you didn't really have a
burger I really had a burger am I going
to vomit actually I have something for
that oh you're prepared I have um a barf
bag okay which these are fantastic all
barf bags should come like
this this our car thank you okay it's
time are you ready oh my God I'm ready
is that your helmet these are for F1
acad
rad I have an abnormally small head
you'll be okay it will just don't break
too hard suan don't make her nervous Tom
she's in safe hands with me I Skydive I
roller coaster I'm more worried about
the burger than you I'm going to grab
this barf
bag all
right you ready I am so ready Susie do
this yeah I can't believe I get to go on
the
track this is so
[Music]
crazy bit of inside CH a really fast
setion in the Formula
One all okay Dre
holy yeah yes I love it
yes I've never felt better in my
life
oh my God I'm so happy I got to do
this got a real race going on
here up to 180
M 180 M
hour yeah baby
yeah oh my God
Susie I I you're so hot
where have you been all my
life I feel sexy when I drive
fast I thought I drove fast until I got
in your car
Susie
wow such a great race you made it
D and next time I promise you if you can
come back to like One race I'll make
sure you drive I feel like I've never
been more alive yeah the adrenaline
that's what I I love
too Sur bad
yes you're so
[Music]
cool